but what makes the Venus fly trap so
appealing to its prey well the plant
produces a sweet nectar that's
irresistible to bugs making the fly trap
a perfect natural insecticide for
gardeners that want to avoid adding
chemicals to their plants if there are a
lot of mosquitoes where you live it
might be a good idea to plant a bunch of
these around your
home some companies have tried selling
the fly trap's extract as a homeopathic
supplement claiming that it fights all
kinds of ailments but these claims have
been mostly debunked so don't get
trapped into thinking it will solve your
medical problems the real question is
could scientists actually grow one big
enough to eat a human well they'd have
to manipulate the plant's DNA it would
take a 120t long fly trap to catch a
6-ft human which probably isn't going to
happen anytime soon